- 「量子情報と計算の理解」へようこそ。
私はJohn Watrousで、IBM Quantumの教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ。
これはシリーズの第7レッスンで、このレッスンでは位相推定問題と、それを量子コンピュータで解く方法について説明する。
次に、前のレッスンで取り上げた整数の素因数分解の問題に位相推定を適用する。
そこで得られるのがShorのアルゴリズムで、整数を多項式コスト、あるいは
必要な基本演算の数ではなく時間で考えるなら多項式時間で素因数分解できる。
これはある意味、量子アルゴリズムの王冠と呼べる存在で、大きな整数を
素因数分解することはほとんどの人には限られた用途しかないかもしれないが、量子コンピュータが古典コンピュータに対して
顕著な優位性をもたらすという仮説を支持する、最も説得力のある証拠の一つであり続けている。レッスンの概要を示す。
まず位相推定問題自体の定義から始め、次にこの問題を量子コンピュータで解く方法について説明する。
一段階ずつ進めていく。まずはウォームアップのようなものから始める。
位相推定問題では、ある実数を近似することが目標で、このウォームアップ部分では
この数の非常に低精度な近似をどう得るかを見ていく。
位相推定問題の解を整数の素因数分解に適用するとき、これだけでは素因数分解には不十分で、
実際にはかなり高精度な近似が必要になる。それでも全体の仕組みを把握するために、このようなウォームアップから始めるのは有益だ。
全体がどう機能するかの感覚をつかむためにね。
次に、より高い精度をどう得るかという問題を取り上げる。これは自然と量子フーリエ変換と呼ばれる演算につながっていく。
この演算が具体的に何であり、量子circuit でどう実装できるかを見ていく。
それが手に入れば、非常に高精度で問題を解く一般的な手順を導き出すために、位相推定に適用できるようになる。
そしてレッスンの最後では、位相推定問題の解が整数を効率的に素因数分解することをどう可能にするかを見る。
具体的には、整数の素因数分解のためのShorのアルゴリズム、あるいは少なくともそれと同等のものが得られる。
この仕組みは、基本的に踏み台となるものを自分たちに与えることで成り立っていて、それがさらにもう一つの問題、位数発見問題と呼ばれるものだ。
特に、位相推定の手順を使って位数発見問題を解く方法を見て、次に整数を
位数発見問題を解くことで素因数分解する方法を見る。スペクトル定理と呼ばれる定理の特殊ケースから始める。
特に、ユニタリ行列に対してこの定理が何を教えてくれるかに焦点を当てる。
スペクトル定理は線形代数と関数解析からの非常に重要な定理だ。
ある特定の線形写像がある形式で表現できることについて面白いことを教えてくれる。これはスペクトル分解と呼ばれることが多く、
多くの理由で有用だ。
先ほど言ったように、ユニタリ行列に対してこの定理が何を教えてくれるかに焦点を当てる。
スペクトル定理はこれより一般的だ。すべての行列に対して成り立つわけではないが、
正規行列と呼ばれる行列のクラスに対しては成り立つ。これにはすべてのユニタリ行列と、ユニタリでない行列の一部が含まれる。
ただ、話を単純にするために、今はユニタリ行列に注目する。このレッスンの目的にはそれだけで十分だから。
ユニタリ行列だけを対象としたスペクトル定理の主張を示す。
UをN×Nのユニタリ行列とする。
定理が言うのは、ベクトルψ₁からψNまでの正規直交基底が必ず存在するということだ。
N個の複素数λ₁からλNとともに、すべて複素単位円上にあって、この方程式のようにUが表現できる。
これはUのスペクトル分解と呼ばれる。すでに述べたように、UがこのようなAの形で書けることを知っておくのはとても便利だ。
特定のユニタリ行列Uを扱うとき、これらのベクトルと数があると便利な場合があるし、また単純に
そのような表現が常に可能だと知っていること自体が、例えばユニタリ行列について特定のことを証明する手段として非常に有用だ。
この定理の主張では、λ₁からλNまでのこれらの数はそれぞれ特定の方法で書かれている。
eの2πiθ乗として書かれていて、各θ、θ₁からθNはそれぞれ実数だ。この書き方については
もう少し後で戻ってくる。
これらのベクトルと数について重要な点は、各ベクトルψKが行列Uの固有ベクトルでなければならないということで、対応する固有値はλKだ。
つまり、ψKにUをかけると、得られるのはλK×ψKだ。
つまりUがこれらのベクトルそれぞれに対してすることは、単に対応する数λKをかけることだ。
一般的な任意のベクトルに対してはUはこのようには機能しないが、固有ベクトルは特別だ。
そして定理が教えてくれるのは、これらの固有ベクトルの正規直交基底が実際に存在するということだ。
ちなみに、ここにあるこの方程式は定理からのUの式と、ベクトルが正規直交であるという事実から導かれる。
UをどのpsiKにも掛けてベクトルの正規直交性を使えば、
項の合計が得られるが、
その中でゼロでない項は一つだけで、
残る一項はこのような形になる。
ここでphase estimation問題を
定義できる。
これはこれから見るように、
少し変わった問題だ。
二つのものが与えられる。まず、ユニタリな量子circuit
の記述が与えられる。
それはある選択されたNに対して
N個のqubitに作用し、このcircuitが
ユニタリだというのは、
すべてのgateがユニタリである、
つまりこのcircuitには
測定が含まれないということを意味する。
次に、N qubitの状態psiが与えられる。
これが変わった部分だ。
この問題には量子状態の入力が実際にあって、
それはこの状態のコピー一つだ。
このシリーズで取り上げた他の計算問題はすべて、
入力はビット列かブラックボックスという形で古典的だった。
それも不思議ではない。日常生活で
出くわす計算問題は古典的なものが多いから、
そういった問題が私たちにとって
一番重要なんだ。
この問題の考え方としては、
サブ問題として現れる、あるいは
現れる可能性があるものだということだ。
これから導き出すphase estimationの手順は、
一般的にサブルーティンとして使うものだ。
より大きな計算の中で、おそらく
私たちが関心を持つ古典的な問題のために。
これはpromise問題になる予定で、
状態psiはただの量子状態ではない。
psiは、与えられたcircuitが記述する
ユニタリ演算Uの固有ベクトルだと
約束されている。
目標は、固有ベクトルpsiに対応する
固有値を求めるか近似することだ。
もう少し正確に
問題を述べよう。
入力は、N qubitに対するユニタリな量子circuit
で、これはビット列として符号化できる。
量子circuitの記述を符号化する好みの方法を使って、
N qubitの状態psiとともに与えられる。
circuitはどう呼んでもいいが、この問題の
記述において本当に重要なのは
ユニタリ演算そのもので、
circuitを実行したときに行われるその演算は
行列Uで記述される。
ただし、Uは行列として与えられるのではなく、
Uを実装する量子circuitの記述だけが与えられる。
すでに述べたpromiseは、
psiがUの固有ベクトルだということだ。
つまり、circuitをpsiで実行すると、
固有値が何であれそれが掛けられたpsiが出てくる。
その場合、それはグローバルな
位相になる。
そして最後に、この問題の出力はpsiに対応する
固有値の近似値で、具体的には
ゼロ以上一未満、つまりゼロを含むが
一を含まない実数thetaの近似を求める。
これはスクリーンに表示された
方程式を満たす。
pisに対応する固有値をこのように
パラメータ化する方法を説明し、
近似の意味を明確にするために、
複素単位円の図を
描いてみよう。
1、i、−1、−iをそれぞれの通常の
位置に置いて、
問題の記述にあるようにthetaでパラメータ化した
円上の任意の点を考える。
これは1から始めて2×π×thetaの角度だけ
回転した点なので、角度はthetaではなく
2×π×thetaだ。
別の考え方としては、1から始めて
円上の距離2π×thetaだけ進むと、
目的の点、e^(2π×theta×i)に
到達するということだ。
複素単位円上のすべての点は、
thetaの一意な選択でこのように表せる。
それはthetaがゼロから一まで変化するにつれて
円を一周するからで、thetaがちょうど一になると、
theta=0と同じ出発点に戻る。
だからゼロは含むが一は含まないんだ。
複素単位円上の各点が、考えている
範囲内のthetaの一意な値に対応することを
確かめるために。
特定のthetaの値を近似する方法はいくつか
考えられるが、ここでは分数でthetaを近似する。
分母はある正の整数Mに対して
2のM乗で、分子は整数y、
ゼロ以上2のM乗マイナス一以下の整数だ。
これはthetaのMビット近似と考えることができて、
この数を二進表記で書くと、
二進小数点の後にYの二進表現が
続く形になる。
decimalではなくbinary pointと言うのは、
decimalが10進数を意味するのに対して、
ここでは2進数の話をしているからで、
考え方は同じだ。
でも、いずれにせよスクリーンに
表示されているように分数として
考えることもできる。
はっきり言っておくと、この文脈で
近似を考えるとき、thetaの値は
ゼロに近いthetaの値と一に近いthetaの値は、実は互いに近い。
例えば、thetaが0.99に等しい場合、このthetaの値をゼロという値で近似すると、
それはかなり良い近似だ。というのも、円を一周して
一に達したときにゼロに戻るとすれば、実際の値との差は百分の一以内に収まるからだ。
「modular one」という用語は、theta equals oneとtheta equals zeroを本質的に同一視する状況を表すのに使われることがある。
重要なのは、単位円上の点E to the two pi I thetaの位置を本当に気にしているということだ。
この目的を念頭に置けば、thetaをこのように近似するという考え方は理にかなっている。
画面に表示されている問題の定式化自体は、thetaへの近似がどの程度良くある必要があるかについて具体的に述べていない。
でも、それは必要に応じて細かく調整できるものだ。
状況によっては、thetaへの低精度の近似で満足することもあるし、他の状況では
非常に高精度の近似が必要になることもある。問題の定式化自体をそれに応じて洗練させることができる。
次に、量子コンピュータを使ってphase estimationの問題をどう解けるか見ていく。まずウォームアップから始めよう。
これは問題の最終的な解ではない。
やることは、phase kickbackという現象を利用して、与えられた固有ベクトルに対応する固有値について何か学ぼうとすることだ。
思い出してほしいのだが、phase estimationの問題では、ある操作Uのユニタリquantum circuitの記述が与えられる。
まず最初にやることは、このcircuitの記述を使って、画面に描かれているようなcontrolled U操作を実装する新しいcircuitを作ることだ。
これはかなり簡単だ。control qubitを追加すればいい。この図では上に描かれているものだ。
そして、この新しいcontrol qubitを、circuitに現れるすべてのgateのcontrolとして使う。
つまり、このcontrol qubitが一にセットされているとすべてのgateが適用され、control qubitがゼロにセットされていると一つも適用されない。
ということは、circuit Uに現れるすべてのgateのcontrolledバージョンが必要になる。しかし、これらの新しいcontrolled gateを
単一のgateとして考える必要はない。選択したgateセットのgateから作られた小さなcircuitとして実装することもできる。
そして、Uのcontrolledバージョンができたら、このcircuitを実行することを考えられる。
まずcontrol qubitをゼロと一の重ね合わせに入れて、与えられた固有ベクトル側にcontrolled U gateを適用する。
そして、controlにHadamard gateを適用して測定する。
解析を進めていく中でなぜこれが理にかなっているかがわかるが、詳細に入る前でも、すぐに類似点が見えてくる。
例えばDeutschのアルゴリズムとの類似点だ。そこでも、いくつかのHadamard gateを適用して測定することで、実効的に調べている。
与えられた操作がここで何をしているのかを。
それはquery gateではなくcontrolled unitaryだが、働いているアイデアは非常によく似ている。
では、circuitが何をするか見てみよう。
初期状態は固有ベクトルpsiで、control qubitのゼロ状態とtensor積をとったものだ。
最初のHadamard gateを適用すると、上のqubitの状態がplus状態に変換され、全体の状態はここに示されているように展開できる。
次にcontrolled U操作を適用する。これがすることは、control qubitが一にセットされているときにpsiにUを適用することだ。
ゼロにセットされているときは適用しない。だから画面に書かれている状態pi twoが得られる。
psiが固有値e to the two pi I thetaを持つUの固有ベクトルであるという事実を使って、状態を簡略化できる。
だから、その固有値は第二項に掛かるが、第一項には掛からない。
そして、tensor積の双線型性を使って簡略化できる。
ここにあるのはphase kickbackという現象だ。しかし今回は、任意のunitaryな操作Uの任意の固有ベクトルpsiに対して起きている。
より具体的には、minus状態に適用されるnot操作ではなく。
これがcontrolled U操作が適用された後の状態だ。
ちなみに、下のn個のqubitの状態がまだ固有ベクトルpsiのままであることに注目する価値がある。
これは素晴らしいことだ。というのも、選択すれば再びそれを使う機会が与えられるからだ。
次に二番目のHadamard gateが実行され、得られる状態がこれだ。
導出のすべての詳細はここに示していないが、Hadamard gateを適用して簡略化すると、これが得られるはずだ。
これが測定直前の状態だ。
この状態に注目して、測定によってthetaについて何が学べるか見てみよう。
上のqubitまたは最右のqubitを測定すると、二つの結果に対してこれらの確率が得られる。
ここでは、sinとcosineを複素指数関数に関連付けるいくつかの基本的な公式を使って、これらの確率を
sinとcosineで表した。
具体的には、ゼロが得られる確率はpi times thetaのcosine二乗で、一が得られる確率は
同じ角度のsin二乗だ。これは理にかなっている
なぜなら、任意の角度について
sin二乗とcos二乗の和は1に等しいから。
つまり確率の和は
期待通り1になる。
そしてこれがthetaの関数として表した
これらの確率のグラフだ。
明確にしておくと、これは
確率そのもののグラフであって、
たとえば単一の確率分布を描いたグラフとは違う。
例えば、thetaが
1/2に等しい場合、紫で描かれている
結果1が得られる確率は1に等しい
一方、青で描かれている
結果0が得られる確率は0だ。
逆に、thetaが1/4または3/4に等しい場合、
2つの結果それぞれが同じ確率になる。
そしてもちろん、thetaの全ての選択に対して、
確率の和はすでに確認した通り1に等しい。
つまりこの手順からthetaが
正確に何かはわからないが、
thetaについての何らかの情報は得られる。
thetaが0に等しいかthetaが1/2に等しいかのどちらかだと
約束されている状況を想像すれば、この手順は
2つの可能性のうち
どちらであるかを正確に教えてくれる。
というわけで、phase kickback現象を使って
固有値について何かを学ぶ簡単な方法だ。
では、固有値について
もっと知るにはどうすればいいか？
そう、これは無知を
道標にできる状況だ。
なぜなら実際には
できることがあまり多くないから。
固有ベクトルsinについてはほとんど何もわからないし、
操作Uについても
あまりわからない。
Uのためのcircuitはあるけれど、
それがひどく混乱した代物で
調べても意味が掴めない可能性もある。
しかし一つの自然な選択肢は
circuitを複数回実行することだ。
特に、今やったのとまったく同じことを試みることができる。
ただし、単一のcontrolled U操作を適用する代わりに、
その操作を2回適用する。あるいは何回でも適用できるが、
何が起きるか見るために2回から始めよう。
実は何が起きるか
かなり単純だ。controlled U操作を2回適用することで、
実質的に固有値を二乗することになる
なぜなら、上のQubitのphaseに
1回ではなく2回kickされるからだ。
そのため、thetaの関数として
結果の確率を考えると、
本質的に周波数を2倍にすることになる。
thetaの各選択肢に対して、結果の確率は
thetaを2倍にしてから
小数部分を取った場合と同じになる
0と1の間の数を得るために。
例えば、thetaが
1/2に等しい場合、固有値は-1だ。
つまりUを2回適用することで実質的に固有値を二乗し、
結果はtheta=0の場合と同じになる。
青で描かれた結果0の確率が1に等しく、
紫で描かれた結果1の確率が0に等しい
ということだ。
これは非常に単純だが、実際にこれを行うことで
thetaについて追加情報を得ることができる。
例えば、thetaが0に等しいかthetaが1/4に等しいかのどちらかを
事前に知っている場合、このcircuitは
2つの可能性のどちらであるかを教えてくれる。
一方、theta=0の場合とtheta=1/2の場合を
もはや区別できなくなってしまう。
そのため、この手順は単一のcontrol U gateを使った
以前のものより一概に優れているわけではない。
しかしこのcircuitも実行することで
追加情報を得ることができる。
controlled U操作を複数回繰り返すことで得られる
追加情報が
1回だけ実行して得られる情報と
どう折り合いをつけられるかはすぐにはわからない。
実際、進める方法は複数ある。
例えば、iterative phase estimationと呼ばれる技術があり、
今まで見てきたようなcircuitを実行することが含まれる。
それらへの若干のバリエーションとともに、
thetaへの近似値を算出する。
しかし、複数のcontrol qubitを持つ単一のquantum circuitを使う、
より伝統的なアプローチと呼べるものを説明しよう
それらのqubitはユニタリ操作Uの
異なる回数の繰り返しを制御する。
まず2つのcontrol qubitでこれがどう
機能するかを説明し、その後少し経ってから
2つ以上のcontrol qubitに一般化する。
2つのcontrol qubitを使う
quantum circuitがこれだ。
上のcontrol Qubitは
単一のU操作を制御し、上から2番目の
Qubitはコピー2つのUを制御する。
つまり、以前見た2つのcircuitを組み合わせて、
単一のコピーを活用する方法だ
我々が持っている固有ベクトルpsiの。
ただし、controlled U操作の後の
Hadamard gateが取り除かれ、
まだ測定がないことに気づくだろう。
これからやることは、このcircuitがどう機能するかを見て、
上の2つのqubitで何をすべきかを
把握することだ
近似しようとしているtheta値について
できる限り多くを学ぶために。
Hadamard gateが実行された後、
画面に表示されている状態になった。
これは次に何が起こるかを見るための、状態を書き表す便利な方法だ。
AゼロとAワンはビットで、上の2つのqubitを2 qubitレジスタとして考えると、
上のqubitに対応するAゼロが下位ビットで、下の制御qubitに対応するAワンが
上位ビットになる。
最初の制御U演算が実行された後、この状態が得られる。
上の制御qubitに対応する古典的状態はAゼロだから、位相キックバックの結果は
このように表せる。そして2番目と3番目の制御U演算が
実行された後、この状態が得られる。
考え方は最初のものと同じだが、今回は制御U演算を2回適用している点が違う。
そのため、これを反映させるために指数部でAワンに2を掛ける。
この式は、AワンとAゼロを二進法表記で0から3の整数として一緒に考えることで簡略化できる。
つまり、2ビット列AワンAゼロを整数の二進エンコーディングとして考えると、
2掛けるAワン足すAゼロが得られる。
理解しておきたいのは、Cat Xと書くとき、Xを二進法表記で長さ2の二進数列として表しているということだ。
では、この時点でこれら2つの制御qubitからthetaについて何が分かるかを考えてみよう。
残りのN個のqubitは最初に与えられたのと同じ状態psiのままだ。これはこのアプローチの素晴らしい点で、
前にも言ったように、thetaについてさらに多くの情報を得たければその状態を再利用できる。
でも今は、この2つの制御qubitから何が学べるかだけを考えよう。
どう進めばいいかを考えるために、thetaがYを4で割ったものに等しいと約束されているとしよう。
Yは0から3の整数だ。
一般的にはthetaがこれら4つの値のどれかとは限らないが、これは考えるべき自然なケースだ。
元の1つの制御qubitバージョンの手順で、thetaがゼロか2分の1のどちらかだと約束された場合、
circuitはどちらかを明らかにすることが分かった。また、制御U演算を2回適用したバージョンでは、
thetaがゼロの場合とthetaが4分の1の場合を完全に区別できた。
だから、新しいcircuitで4つのケースを区別できることを期待できる。
本質的には、問題を約束問題という概念を使って簡単にしており、どう進めるかを見えるようにしている。
一般的に、これは悪い考えじゃない。問題があって解き方が分からなければ、より簡単にしてみるといい。
簡単にした問題を解けたなら、得られた洞察がより一般的な問題を解く助けになるかもしれない。
もし簡単にした問題も解けなければ、より一般的な問題にはまだ準備ができていないということだ。
だから、解けるまでどんどん簡単にしていけばいい。
とはいえ、問題に戻ろう。Yの各可能な値に対して2 qubit状態を定義しよう。
つまり、phi Yはthetaが具体的にYを4で割った値として選ばれたときの、画面上部に示された状態に等しい。
そして、明示的に書き出したその4つの状態がここにある。
改めて言うと、Yがゼロ、1、2、3のときにthetaがYを4で割ったものに等しく、circuitを実行すると、
Yの正しい値に対応するこれら4つの状態のうちの1つが残る。
あとはそれがどれかを特定したい。
問題は、それが可能かどうかだ。
その答えはイエスだ。なぜなら、この4つの状態は直交しているからだ。
どの対の内積を計算してもゼロになる。
直交しているため、射影測定によって完全に区別できる。
特に、ここにあるように各ベクトルに対して1つの射影を定義することでそのような測定を表現できる。
これは正規直交基底があれば常に機能する。この特定のケースについては、レッスン3で見た定義と照らし合わせて確認できる。
そうしたければの話だが。つまり、タスクを達成することは可能だという結論になる。
タスクとは、画面上部に示された状態からYの値を知ることだ。
quantum circuitでそれをやりたければ、これから説明する通りに進められる。
まず、列が順番に並んだ4つのベクトルであるユニタリ行列Vを定義できる。
その行列は画面下部に示された標準基底状態への作用を持ち、
行列を書き下してどんな形か見ることができる。
Vは各標準基底状態kappa YをベクトルphiYに写すから、V dagger、
つまりVの逆行列をphi Yに適用すると、対応する標準基底状態に逆向きに変換される。
できることは、circuit から得られた状態に
V dagger を適用することだ。
そして標準基底測定を行えば、
探している数 Y が得られる——
2桁の2進数文字列として表される形でね。
先に進む前に、ユニタリ行列 V について
もう少し話しておこう。
これは特殊な行列で、
見たことがある人もいるかもしれない。
4次元ベクトルへの線形演算に
対応する行列で、離散フーリエ変換として知られている。
より正確に言うと、離散フーリエ変換は
任意の正の整数次元に対して定義できて、
少し後で一般的な形を見ていく。
これが次元が4のときの
具体的な形だ。
離散フーリエ変換については
様々な観点から考えられる。
純粋に抽象的に、行列で表せるベクトルへの
線形写像として捉えることができる。
また、ベクトルが与えられたとき
この線形写像を適用した結果を計算するという
計算問題として考えることもできる。
これは非常に重要な計算問題で、
その計算を行うための非常に効率的なアルゴリズムが存在する——
高速フーリエ変換として知られているものだ。
実際、例えば信号処理においてこれほど重要な問題なので、
高速フーリエ変換は多くの人に
これまでに発見された最も重要で
影響力のあるアルゴリズムの一つだと
考えられている。
離散フーリエ変換を、量子状態ベクトルに
適用できるユニタリ量子演算として
考えることもできる。
そのように考えるとき、
量子フーリエ変換、略して QFT と呼ぶ。
数学的には離散フーリエ変換と本質的に同じものだが、
量子フーリエ変換と呼ぶのは
量子状態ベクトルに適用される演算だと
明確にするためだ。
では行列の名前を V から QFT four に変えよう、
その演算が実際には量子フーリエ変換であるという
事実を反映するために。
私たちが考え出した演算は実際には
量子フーリエ変換だということを。
これが、theta が Y over four に等しいと
約束されているとき Y の値を学ぶための
完全な circuit だ——
Y がゼロ、1、2、または3の場合だ。
明確にしておくと、量子フーリエ変換の逆、
つまり QFT four dagger を適用している——
4つの可能な状態のうちの1つを標準基底状態 |Y⟩ に戻すためで、
そうすることで測定によって Y を取り出せる。
これが位相推定問題の約束バージョンを考えて
得られる circuit だ——theta が
ゼロ、4分の1、2分の1、または4分の3と
約束されているものだが、それを妨げるものは何もない。
この circuit を任意の theta の値で
実行することを。
そうした場合、
得られる4つの可能な結果の確率がここに示されている。
Y の4つの可能な値それぞれに色があって、
プロットは theta の関数として
各値の確率を示している。
例えば theta が4分の3に等しい場合、
確率1で結果3が得られる——
他の3つの結果の確率はすべてゼロだ、
問題の約束バージョンを考えれば
すでにわかっていることだ。
theta が4分の3に近いがちょうど4分の3ではない場合、
他の結果に対していくらかの非ゼロ確率が生じる——
それでも高い確率で結果3が得られる。
theta が Y over four に等しくない場合でも、
測定から得た結果を4で割ったものを
theta の推測または近似として
考えることができる。
推測が間違っている可能性もあるが、
それでも情報を提供してくれている。
プロットから学べることの一つは、
最良の近似には常に最も高い確率が
関連付けられているということだ。
最良の近似というのは、Y over four のうち
theta の真の値に最も近い値のことを言う——
モジュラー1の意味でね。
最悪の場合は theta が Y over four の
2つの値のちょうど中間にある場合だ。
例えば theta が8分の3、つまり0.375に等しい場合、
この場合の近似値は
4分の1と4分の2、つまり2分の1が
同等に良いことがわかる。
この特定のケースでは、
最良の近似が1つではなく実際には2つある。
そして結果1と結果2が
得られる可能性は同等だ。
他の2つの結果である0と3は、4で割ったとき
theta に対してあまり良い近似を与えないが、
実際にはある確率で現れる——
どちらの場合も10%をわずかに下回る程度のようだ。
この手順は完璧ではないが、情報を提供してくれる。
注目すべきは、theta に関わらず、
常に最良の近似を引き出すことが保証されているということだ——
または同率のときは2つの最良近似のうちの一方を、
その確率は40%をわずかに上回る程度のようだ。
thetaが近似値に近いほど、Yの対応する値が観測される確率は高くなる。
これは単一の制御qubitを使う場合と比べて、かなり大きな改善だ。
これは実際、2つの制御qubitを使うことを選んだ場合の位相推定の手順だ。
次にやることは、この手順を自然な形で一般化することで、2つの制御qubitで止まらず、
選んだ数だけ制御qubitを使うようにする。
そして、手順を一般化して制御qubitを増やしていくことで、thetaの近似精度をどんどん高められることがわかる。
それが一般的な位相推定の手順になる。
位相推定の手順を2つの制御qubitから好きな数に一般化するには、量子Fourier変換が他の次元でどう定義されるかを理解する必要がある。
量子Fourier変換が他の次元でどう定義されるかを理解する必要がある。
また、それをquantum circuitでどう実装できるかについても議論する必要がある。
次元が任意の正の整数Nの場合の量子Fourier変換の定義はこれだ。
ここでは、この演算を古典的な状態がゼロからN-1までのシステムに対する演算として考えている。
そして、この演算を記述する行列はDirac記法を使って表されている。
また、Nが4に等しい場合にすでに見たものと結びつけるために、標準基底状態への作用という観点からも記述できる。
Nが1に等しい場合の見た目はこうだ。あまり面白い場合ではないが。
Nが2に等しい場合はこれで、この場合に得られるのはHadamard演算だとわかる。
Nが3に等しい場合の量子Fourier変換はこれだ。
Nが4に等しい場合は、すでに見ている。
最後の例として、Nが8に等しい場合はこれだ。
Nが4の場合と同様に、これらは各次元の離散Fourier変換と関連づける行列だ。
だが、量子演算として考えたい場合は量子Fourier変換と呼ぶ。
ちなみに、離散Fourier変換を行列として考える場合、1/√Nの先頭の因子が含まれないことがある。
だが、ユニタリ行列であることを保証するためにその因子が必要だ。
また、各指数にマイナス符号がつく場合とつかない場合がある。
基本的には個人の好みであって、変換の本質的な性質は変わらない。
いずれにせよ、量子Fourier変換は画面に書かれているとおりに定義する。
よく使われる非常に便利な略記法があって、このレッスンの後半で使う。
それは、ここにあるように複素数omega Nを定義することだ。
具体的にはeの2πi/N乗で、サインとコサインを使って書くこともできる。
ここに示したとおりだ。N乗するとが1になることから、この数をNの1の累乗根と呼ぶことがある。
いくつかの例を示す図がこれだ。
omega 1は1に等しく、omega 2は-1に等しく、omega 4はiに等しい。
一般に、omega Nを求めるには、N人でピザを分けるように単位円をN等分に切り分けることをイメージできる。
omega Nは最初のピースの角にある。もう一方の角が1にあると仮定してだ。
特にNが大きくなるにつれてピースはどんどん小さくなり、omega Nは1にどんどん近づく。
この記法を使うと、量子Fourier変換をもう少しすっきりした形で表せる。
この記法は、このレッスンの後半で見るように、物事をシンプルに保つのに役立つことがある。
Nが2の冪乗の場合、量子Fourier変換の効率的なquantum circuit実装がある。
これから見ていく。量子Fourier変換はどんな次元Nに対しても定義する傾向があるが、必要になるのは
位相推定の手順を一般化するためにNが2の冪乗の場合だけだ。
この実装では、画面に示したような制御位相gateを使う。
2つの制御がalphaという数と一緒に接続されているように見える。この場合はalphaだ。
このgateの作用はここに示した行列によって記述される。
これらは文字通り制御位相gateで、位相gateを制御する制御qubitがあることを意味する。
位相gateはレッスン1でずっと前に見た。
ただし位相gateに限っては、どちらのqubitが制御でどちらがターゲットかは実際には関係ない。
それはレッスン2でZ gateの具体的なケースで見た。
その概念を踏まえて、量子Fourier変換の実装方法に移ることができる。
この実装は再帰的な性質を持っていて、おそらく一番わかりやすい説明の仕方は、簡単に一般化できる例を挙げることだ。
Nが32の場合にどうやるか見てみよう。
つまり、5つのqubitがある。
明確にしておくと、この5つのqubitの標準基底状態を、2進数表記を使って0から31までの整数に対応させている。
最初にやることは、最下位のqubitを除いた全qubitに対して、N=16の場合の量子フーリエ変換を行うことだ。
最下位のqubitというのは一番上にあるやつで、それがこの構成の再帰的な部分だ。
この操作を実装するには、同じパターンに従う必要があるが、qubitが1つ少なくなる。
そして基底ケースでは、qubitが1つだけになり、その場合の量子フーリエ変換はただのHadamard gateになる。
一番上のqubitを除く全qubitにQFTを適用したら、図に示されている位相を使って、いくつかの制御位相gateを適用する。
次に、一番上のqubitにHadamard gateを適用して、いくつかのswap gateを使ってqubitを少し入れ替える。
これらのswap gateは、qubitを巡回置換する効果があり、構成をうまく機能させるために必要だ。
Nの選択肢が2の冪である限り、まったく同じパターンに従うことができて、常に制御位相gateから始める。
その際、一番下のqubitのalphaはpiの2分の1で、図の左に移動するたびに2で割っていく。
これで後続の位相が得られる。で、この構成がうまくいくことは全然自明じゃない。
なぜうまくいくのかは、このビデオでは説明しない。
なぜうまくいくのかの詳細に興味があれば、そのレッスンの文章コンテンツで確認できる。
ただ言っておくと、ここで利用されているのは離散フーリエ変換の基本的な構造だ。
実際、それは高速フーリエ変換を機能させる全く同じ構造だ。
別の言い方をすると、高速フーリエ変換を見ると、それをquantum circuitsの観点から考えることができる。
そしてこれがそこから得られるcircuitだ。
では、この実装には合計でいくつのgateが必要なんだろう？
それを把握するために、SMをMつのqubitがある場合に必要なgateの数としよう。
Mが1の場合、gate は1つだけ必要だ。なぜなら、この場合QFTはただのHadamard操作だから。
Mが2以上の場合、必要なgateはこれらだ。
まず、M-1つのqubitに対する量子フーリエ変換に、その数がいくらであれ、SM-1個のgateが必要だ。
さらにM-1個の制御位相gateと、M-1個のswap gateが必要だ。
そして追加でHadamard gateが1つ。
というわけで、MがちょうどAの場合とMが2以上の場合の両方について、SMの式はこうなる。
これは漸化式と呼ばれるものの例で、アルゴリズムの分析では非常によく出てくる。
この特定の式はとてもシンプルで、いわゆる閉じた形の式があり、それは和を計算することで求められる。
正確に言うと、SMの値はM個の連続した奇数の和で、それはMの2乗に等しい。
これは以前に見たことがあるかもしれないし、いつかの時点で気づいたことがあるかもしれない。
形式的な証明に興味があれば、Mに関する帰納法でこの公式が正しいことを証明するのは割と簡単だ。
というわけで以上だ。M個のqubitに対する量子フーリエ変換をMの2乗個のgateで実装できる。
追加の簡単な補足をいくつかしておこう。
まず、説明した全てのswap gateが実際に必要なわけじゃない。
制御位相gateが作用するqubitを適切に調整する限り、全てのswap gateを実質的に最後にまとめることができる。
そうすれば、合計で切り捨ててM/2個のswap gateだけが必要になる。
それでもコストは2次になるけど、gateの数はこうやって減らせる。
そして最後の補足として、かなり良い近似で妥協する気があれば、コストをさらに下げることができる。
例えば、Mが大きくなると、制御位相gateの多くは恒等操作にかなり近くなる。
そして非常に近いものを取り除くことで、かなり良い近似を保ちながらgateをかなり節約できる。
また、量子フーリエ変換を、深さが小さい非常に浅いcircuitで近似することも可能で、そうしたい場合に使える。
さて、異なる次元における量子フーリエ変換が何であるか、そして次元が2の冪の場合にどう実装できるかがわかったので、
位相推定の手順に戻って、M個の制御qubitを任意の数だけ使う場合にどう一般化できるかを見ていこう。
Mを任意に選んだ場合のquantum circuitとしてこの手順がどう見えるかを示す。
上にM個の制御qubitがあり、全て0状態に初期化されていると仮定する。
それぞれにHadamard gateを適用して、次にそれぞれがユニタリ操作Uの何らかの冪を適用する制御qubitとして使われる。
各制御qubitに対してUを適用する回数を
倍にしていくところだ。
このダイアグラムでは、controlled U gateを
何度も適用する様子を示す代わりに、
ボックスの中にUの累乗を書いて表現している。
これはdiagramをより明確にして、
画面に収まるよう
スペースを節約するためだ。
さて、この手順についてまず気づくべきことは、
コストが非常に高くなる可能性があるという点だ。
具体的には、各制御qubitに対して
U演算を適用する回数が
倍になっていく。
そしてこれを単純にcontrolled U gateを
必要な回数だけ繰り返すことで実現しようとすると、
巨大なcircuitになってしまう。Mの数に対して
指数的に大きくなるんだ。
これは一般的に大きな制約で、特に
固有値の精度の高い近似を得る能力が
制限されてしまう。
ただし、後ほど取り上げる素因数分解の
特定のケースでは、幸運なことに
あるトリックが使えて、
この指数的なコストの爆発を
回避できることがわかっている。
だが一般的な任意のユニタリ演算Uに対しては
それは不可能で、
制御qubitの数を増やすと
大きな代償を払うことになる。
このビデオではcircuitの詳細な分析には
踏み込まず、代わりに
測定直前の状態について
かなりシンプルな式があることだけ
触れておく。それが画面に表示されている。
その状態から各結果の確率の式が
導けて、それはこのような形になる。
この式さえあれば、それについて
推論できるし、実際この式だけで
話を進めるのに十分だ。
さっきも言ったように、このビデオでは
詳細には入らないが、レッスンの
テキストコンテンツで確認できる。
実はそれほど複雑じゃない。
興味があればぜひ見てみてくれ。分析を
進めると、状況は
Mが2の場合とそれほど変わらないが、
より高い精度が得られることがわかる。
特に、最も良い近似か
2番目に良い近似の一つを得る確率について
まず考えられる。
これはここに書いてあるように表現できる。
絶対値の下の添字1は
無視してもかまわない。
これは単に、thetaが0と
thetaが1を同じものとして考える円上の
近似について話していることを
自分に思い出させるための記号だ。
ここでのポイントは、YをMの2乗分の
Yがthetaにできるだけ近くなるような
Yの選び方を考えているということだ。
そしてMが2の場合と同様に、
この結果Yを少なくとも40%の確率で
得ることが保証されている。
実際、確率はpi二乗分の4以上で、
これは40%をわずかに上回る。
急いでいるときはpi二乗の近似として
10はそう悪くない。
これは実に驚くべきことだ。分数Y割る
2のM乗としてthetaに最も近い
近似を得るという話で、
YはYは整数だ。そして40%を超える確率で
最良の近似が得られるわけだ。
精度が低い近似についても
考えることができる。
具体的に、Yがあまり良くない場合を
想像してみよう。さらに具体的には、
thetaと同じ形の、thetaとY割る2のMの間に
位置するより良い近似が
存在する場合を仮定すると、
それは画面に書かれているように
表現できる。
そのような場合、このYを得る確率は
比較的小さく、最大でも25%だ。
実際にはもっと低くなるが、25%というのは
かなりシンプルな分析から得られる値で、
十分に使える。
例として、制御qubitを2つではなく
3つ使った場合のプロットを示す。
今回は図が煩雑になりすぎないよう、
結果3、4、5の確率だけを
プロットしている。
例えばthetaが2分の1のとき、
結果4が得られることが保証されている。
そのため近似として8分の4、つまり
2分の1を取る。2の3乗が8だからだ。
この場合は完全に正解だ。thetaが
例えば8分の3より2分の1に近い限り、
結果4を得る確率は
結果3を得る確率より高くなる。
そして確率は
やはり40%以上だ。
Mが4のときのプロットを示す。曲線は
ほぼ同じ形をしているが、
2倍ズームインされている。
今度プロットされている結果は7、8、9で、
近似としてこれらの数を16で割った値を
使う。8ではなく16だ。
もう一つ、Mを5に増やした場合の
プロットも示す。
またさらに
2倍ズームインされる。
これがそのプロットだ。曲線は
ほぼ同じ形をしているが、
精度が実質的に2倍になっている。
以前と同様に、thetaへの最良の近似を40%以上の確率で得られた。
これはかなり驚異的だ。だが40%が信頼度として十分でないなら、
この手順を少数回実行して、結果の最頻値、つまり最も多く現れる値を取るという方法がある。
そうすれば、thetaへの非常に良い近似が得られる可能性が極めて高くなる。
ちなみに、位相推定の手順を実行するたびに、固有ベクトルは変化しないことを覚えておいてほしい。
だから、このように手順を複数回実行することができる。
要するに、thetaに関する統計を集めているわけで、こうすることでthetaへの非常に精密な近似が得られる
というのが要点だ。しかも非常に高い信頼度で、そのためにそれほど多くの反復は必要ない。
これが位相推定手順の仕組みだ。
レッスンの最後の部分では、位相推定の手法を整数因数分解問題に適用する。
動画の冒頭で述べたように、これがどう機能するかというと、位数発見問題として知られる中間問題を考えるわけだ。
位相推定を使って位数発見問題を解く方法を見ていき、次に位数発見問題を解くことで
効率的に整数を因数分解できることを簡単に説明する。
第二の部分は完全に古典的なもので、この動画では基本的なアイデアのみを要約する。
だがまず、位数発見問題から始めよう。
まず、便利な記法を整えよう。
任意の正の整数Nに対して、ZNをゼロからN-1までの整数として定義する。
例えば、Z1は単一要素ゼロを持ち、Z2はゼロと1の要素を持つ。
Z3はゼロ、1、2の要素を持つ、といった具合だ。
つまりZNは集合だ。
だが、集合以上のものとして考えることもできる。ZN上の加法や乗法といった算術演算について考えることができる
NによるmodularとしてZNを定義することで。
例えば、Nが7に等しいとしよう。
3と5はZ7の要素で、それらを掛け合わせると15になる
これは7で割ったとき余りが1になる。
これを、3×5はmodulo 7で1と合同、と書くこともある。ここに書かれているようにね。
だが、単純に3×5は1と等しいと書くこともできる。
もちろん3×5は通常1とは等しくなく、15だ。
だがZ7で作業していること、つまり乗法がmodulo 7で定義されていることが明らかなとき、
単純に3×5は1と等しいと書ける。
さて、任意の正のNに対してZNの要素の中には、NとのGCDが1に等しいものがある
そうでないものもある。そしてNとのGCDが1に等しい要素は特別だ。
こうした要素だけの集合をZNスター（ZN*）と書く。
例えば、Z21スター（Z21*）を見てみよう。
Z21の要素は21個あるが、そのうち12個が21とのGCDが1で、残りはそうでない。
特に、Z21の要素のうち3または7で割り切れるものはスキップする。
この集合が特別な理由はいくつかあって、その一つは、ZN*の要素があれば
その数の正の整数べき乗を考えると、最終的に必ず1になる、
先ほどと同様にmodulo Nの乗法の話をしているが。
1を与える最小の正の整数べき乗を、その要素の位数と呼ぶ。
例えば、Z21*でA=4の要素について考えよう。
4×4は16で、modulo 21で1と等しくないが、さらに4を掛けると、
64になり、64 modulo 21は1と等しい。
だから4のmodulo 21での位数は3だ。
このようにして1になることは、ZN*の全ての要素で常に起こる。
ちなみに、ZN*に含まれないZNの要素では決して起こらない。
つまり、NとのGCDが1に等しいことは、これが起こるために必要十分条件だ。
N=21の例を締めくくると、Z21*の各要素についてこれが成立する最小の正の整数べき乗を示したが、
それぞれ一つ一つ確認できる。
これで位数発見問題を述べられる。それは単純に、ZN*の与えられた要素の位数を見つけることだ。
正確に言うと、入力は
GCDが1に等しい2つの正の整数AとNで、
出力はAのR乗が
N を法として1と合同となる
最小の正の整数R、
言い換えれば、AのR乗が1に等しくなる最小の正の整数Rだ。
ZNにおける演算を行っていると仮定してのことだ。
これは計算上困難な問題だと考えられており、
それを解く効率的な古典アルゴリズムは知られていない。
これから議論するように、この問題は少なくとも
整数の素因数分解と同程度に困難だ。つまり、位数発見を解くアルゴリズムがあれば、
そのアルゴリズムを使って整数の
素因数分解問題を効率的に解けるということだ。
実は逆方向も成り立つ。つまり、素因数分解の
アルゴリズムがあれば、それを使って
位数発見問題を解けるということだ。
したがって、この2つの問題は
計算困難性という観点では
ある意味で等価なんだ。
では、位相推定を使って量子コンピュータ上で
位数発見問題をどう解くか見ていこう。
問題同士のつながりを作るために、古典的な状態集合がANである
システムがあると想像しよう。
ZNスター内の要素Aの任意の選択に対して、
ここにあるような演算MAを定義する。
MAが行うことを言葉で言うと、Aを掛けることで、
この掛け算はNを法としたものだ。
このレッスンの残りの部分では、
ket内の式はNを法として計算されると常に考えるようにしてほしい。
物事を単純に保ち、mod Nを何度も
書き続けなくてもいいようにするためだ。
これはユニタリー演算だが、
それはAがZNスターにある場合に限る。
AとNのGCDが1でなければ、
この演算はユニタリーにならない。
例を挙げよう。Nが15でAが2（Z15スターに属す）の場合、
これがM2の作用だ。
この例をしばらく見れば、
この作用によってZNの要素が
単に置換されているとわかるだろう。
つまり決定論的かつユニタリーで、
行列として見ると、MAは置換行列だということだ。
そしてこれが主なアイデアだ。MAの固有値は
Aの位数と
非常に密接に関係している。位相推定を使ってこれらの
固有値を十分に近似することで、
Aの位数を特定できる。では、MAの固有ベクトルと固有値は
一体何なのか？
全部は必要ない、
一部だけあればいい。
簡単な例から始めよう。
これがMAの固有ベクトルで、サイゼロと名付けた。
ket 1、ket a の和として与えられ、
ket Aの2乗、…とRマイナス1乗まで続き、
全体をRの平方根で割った形だ。
単位ベクトルにするためだ。ここでRはAの位数だ。
このレッスンの残りの部分では、
RはAの位数を表す文字として使う。
だから、Rが出てくるときは常に、
今話しているAの位数のことだ。
この固有ベクトルに対応する
固有値は1だ。
それはMAをこのベクトルに
適用してみれば確認できる。
MAはAを掛けるから、
各指数を1増やせばよく、こうなる。
でも、Aの位数はRだからAのR乗は1に等しい。
その置き換えをすることができる。
でも、それは最初と同じベクトルだ。
ket をシャッフルしただけで、和を取っているから
何も変わらない。
つまり、MAかけるサイゼロはサイゼロに等しい。
よって、固有値1を持つ
MAの固有ベクトルだ。
これは固有ベクトルのとても単純な例で、
他の固有ベクトルを特定するために、
このレッスンで先ほど使った記法を思い出そう。
オメガRは単位円上の複素数で、
Eを2 π i の
R乗に取ることで得られる。前回はRの代わりにNを使ったが、
NをRに置き換えても同じように機能する。
この数が必要なのは、
これから特定するMAの他の固有ベクトルに
現れることになるからだ。
この記法を思い出したところで、
サイ1と名付けたこのベクトルもMAの固有ベクトルであると
観察できる。
サイゼロと似ていて、全く同じketがあり、
和を取ってRの平方根で割っている。
ただし今回は、各ketに
様々な位相が掛かっている。
Aには負の1乗のオメガR、Aの2乗には負の2乗のオメガR、
…とオメガRの負のRマイナス1乗まで続く。
Aのket内の指数が何であれ、オメガRの指数は
常に負の1倍になっている。
詳しくは説明しないが、ビデオを見直して
必要に応じて一時停止できるよう
スクリーンに表示してある。
掛け算を実行して、AのR乗が1に等しいという事実を
使って再び簡略化すると、
オメガのR乗が1に等しいという非常に重要な事実もあわせて使うと、
再びMAの固有ベクトルが得られるとわかる。
今回の簡略化では、omega R の因数を取り出す必要がある。そうすることで、確かに固有ベクトルが得られることがわかる
そして、その omega R のベクトルが、この固有ベクトルに対応する固有値を表している。
つまり、これが NA の
2番目の固有ベクトルと固有値のペアだ。
まったく同じ論法を使って、追加の固有ベクトルを特定できる。実は、omega R を
0 から R マイナス1 の各 J に対して omega R の J 乗に置き換えると、常に固有ベクトルが得られる。
そして対応する固有値は omega R の J 乗になる。
これには実際、
psi ゼロと psi 1 も含まれていて、それはすでに見た通りだ。
さらに R マイナス2 個の別の固有ベクトルと固有値のペアも含まれている。
すべて基本的に同じ方法で成り立っていて、検証するには A の R 乗が1に等しいことを知っておけばいい
それと同様に、omega R の
R 乗も1に等しいことも必要だ。
MA には例えばケット0 のような他の固有ベクトルもあるが、それらは役に立たないから気にしなくていい。
気にすべきなのは、psi ゼロから psi R マイナス1 だけだ。
少しの間 psi 1 に注目してみよう。これらの固有ベクトルがなぜ重要なのかを理解してみるために
そして、それらが
求めようとしている位数 R について何を教えてくれるかを見ていこう。
固有ベクトル psi 1 が
与えられたとすると、次のような方法で
R を求めることができる。
まず、この固有ベクトルに対して、操作 MA を実装する quantum circuit を使って
位相推定を行う。
得られるのは、この場合 1/R である theta の近似値だ。
次に、R を求めたいのに 1/R の近似値しかないから、自然なのは逆数を計算することで、
それを最も近い整数に
丸めることだ。R は整数でなければならないから、こうして丸める必要がある。
ただし、1/R を正確に持っているわけではなく、その近似値しかない。
でも近似が十分精度が高ければ、丸めたときに R が得られる。
それがまさに求めているものだ。
そこで問題なのは、逆数を計算して丸めることで R を正しく求めるのに、どれだけの精度が必要かということだ。
言い換えると、これをうまく機能させるには、
近似値はどれだけ正確である必要があるのか？
実は、かなり正確な近似が必要だということがわかっている。
例えば、1/R と 1/(R+1) や 1/(R-1) を
混同する余裕はない。
その2つの分数、1/(R+1) と
1/(R-1) は、R が大きいとき 1/R にかなり近い。
ただ、かなり正確な近似が必要だとはいえ、
馬鹿げた精度まで必要なわけではない。
近似が
画面上に示されている不等式を
満たせば、丸めることで
正しい答えが得られることが示せる。
このビデオではそれを論証しようとは思わないが、詳細に興味があれば、レッスンの文書資料で説明されている。
そしてその精度を目指すなら、位相推定の手順で使う
制御 qubit の数は
N の長さの2倍に
1を加えたものと等しければ十分だ。
ここで、前のレッスンで扱ったように、N の長さとは N を2進数で表すのに必要なビット数のことだ。
ちなみに、少なくとも40%の確率で最良の近似を得ることで満足できて、信頼度を上げようとしない場合は、
先ほど説明したように、プラス1は実際には必要ない。
いずれにせよ、必要な制御 qubit の数は、2進数文字列として書かれた N の長さに対して線形だということがわかっている。
固有ベクトル psi 1 があれば、位相推定を使って R を求めることができる。ただし、十分な精度を使う必要がある。
残念ながら、この固有ベクトルを手に入れるのはそれほど簡単ではない。
では、別の問いを立ててみよう。
psi 1 を持っていないが、
ランダムに選んだ J に対する psi J を持っているとしよう。
それでも R が何かわかるだろうか？あるいは、少なくとも R について何かわかるだろうか？
答えはイエスで、少なくとも平均的には
R について何かわかる。
今見た方法に非常によく似た方法を使って、J/R を求めることができる。
ただし、重要な違いがある。
まず、先ほどまったく同じことをしたように、固有ベクトル psi J に対して位相推定の手順を実行する。
そして得られるのは、先ほどの 1/R とは違って、
J/R の近似値だ。
でも今は小さな問題がある。逆数を計算しても R は得られず、R/J が得られてしまう。
ちなみに、J が何かを知っていると仮定しているわけではなく、ランダムな J に対する psi J が与えられているだけで、
J が何かは教えてもらえない。では、どうすればいいか？
実は、助けになる有名な
古典アルゴリズムがある。
それが連分数アルゴリズムだ。
このアルゴリズムにできることは、近似値 Y / 2 の M 乗を取って、どの分数 U/V が
既約分数として、かつ U と V がどちらも N より小さい整数として、近似値に最も近いかを教えてくれることだ。
本当に魅力的なアルゴリズムだ。興味があるなら、ぜひ調べてみるべきだ。
実はこれ、GCDを計算するための
ユークリッドのアルゴリズムと深く関係している。
でも、このビデオでは
これ以上は触れない。
ここで重要なのは、分子と分母が
あまり大きくないある分数への良い近似があれば、
そのアルゴリズムで分数を復元できる。それがここでやっていることだ。
そして今、前回とまったく同じ問いが残る。
つまり、どれだけの精度が必要か、ということだ。
前回使ったのとまったく同じ
上界が、この場合にも成り立つとわかった。
だから、前回とまったく同じやり方で
Mを選べば、ここでもうまくいく。
ただし、これで必ずしも
Rがわかるとは限らない。
十分な精度を使えばわかるのは
J/Rだが、それは既約分数になっているはずだ。
だから、ランダムに選んだJがRと公約数を持つ
という不運な場合もある。
その場合は隠れてしまう。最悪の場合、たとえばJがゼロになって、
まったく何もわからないこともある。
でも、何もわからないのは
文字通りその場合だけだ。
一般には、少なくともRの
自明でない因子は得られる。異なるJのランダムサンプルを
psi Jとして得られれば、観測したすべての分母の
最小公倍数を計算することで
高確率でRを復元できる。
そして実際、必要なサンプル数はそれほど多くない。
結論として、Jの選び方によってはRの因子が隠れることもあるが、
ランダムな選択であれば
Rの因子をいつまでも
隠し続けることはできない。
以上がアイデアだ。次は実装を考え、
特にコストがどれだけかかるかを調べる必要がある。
アイデアの本質は、ZN*の与えられた元Aのorderを
計算するために、位相推定の手順を
演算MAに適用することだ。
大文字Nの長さ（これを小文字nで表す）
の関数として、このコストを求めてみよう。
これが位相推定のcircuitだ。circuit下部には
小文字n個のqubitが必要で、
ZNの元を2進数で表すために使う。
上部にはN個の制御qubit、下部には小文字n個のqubitがある。
この授業の前半で使った
名前とちょうど一致していて都合がいい。
circuit全体に必要なgateの数を数えるために、
まず制御ユニタリ演算のコストに注目しよう。
前回の授業、授業6のテクニックを使えば、
N法での算術の効率的な古典アルゴリズムを使い、
O(n²)個のgateでMAを実装できる。
このビデオでは詳細を省くが、これまで話してきた
いくつかの事柄と同様に、授業の文書資料で詳しく読める。
ただし、MAだけを
実装すれば十分というわけではない。
MAの2乗、4乗、8乗、
そのまた次と、
MAのMについて指数的な冪乗まで
実装する必要がある。
そして、十分な精度を得るためには
Mを小文字nの線形にする必要があるとわかっている。
これは大きな懸念点で、
先ほども触れた。
MAの冪を単純にMAを繰り返すことで実装しようとすると、
問題になる。そうしたMAの繰り返しすべてが
指数的なコストを招くからだ。
幸い、このコスト爆発を避けるトリックが使える。
やり方は次の通りだ。必要な冪Kそれぞれについて、
まず、AのK乗のmod N
を計算する。
これが授業6で触れた
剰余累乗問題だ。
これは効率的に解けるし、
古典的なコンピュータでできることだ。
この計算は量子circuit で
行う必要はまったくない。
その結果をBとしよう。
つまりBはZN*の元だ。
次に、MAのK乗の代わりに、
MBのcircuitをそのまま使う。
以上だ。BはZN*のある元なので、
MBの実装コストはO(n²)だ。
要するに、量子circuitで冪乗するのではなく、
ZN上で冪乗しているわけだ。
でも実際に得られる演算はどちらも同じだ。
AをK回掛けているだけだから。
これはある意味奇跡に近い。これがなければ、
量子コンピュータでorder finding問題を解いたり
整数を効率的に因数分解したりすることは
できなかっただろう。
そして、冪乗を含む制御ユニタリ演算それぞれが
O(n²)のコストで実装できるとわかれば、
必要なgateの総数を
数えられる。
N個のHadamard gateがあり、MはO(n)に等しいので、
コストはO(n)だ。
M個の制御ユニタリ演算があり、それぞれのコストはビッグOのN二乗だ。
つまりここでの合計コストは
ビッグOのN三乗になる。
そして最後に、量子フーリエ変換のコストはビッグOのn二乗だ。
よって合計コストはビッグOのN三乗だ。
特に、モジュラー冪乗のトリックを使っても、
制御ユニタリ演算のコストが
支配的になることがわかる。
それでも、コストは
小文字nの多項式だ。
他にも古典的な計算が必要で、
たとえばモジュラー冪乗の計算や
連分数アルゴリズムの実行などがある。
しかしそれらの計算も
多項式コストだ。実際、それらもビッグOのN三乗演算で実行できる。
残る問題はひとつだけで、それはこれらの固有ベクトルのひとつを
手に入れる必要があるということだ。
どうすればいいのか？
解決策は実はとてもシンプルだ。circuitを
固有ベクトル上で実行しなければいい。
状態「1」、つまり数字1の二進数
エンコーディング上で実行するだけでいい。
これをZNの元として考えている。
では、図の中でその
置き換えをしよう。
これが成り立つ理由は、まさにここにあるこの式だ。
状態ket 1は実際、
これまで話してきたR個の固有ベクトルの
一様な重ね合わせになっている。
それはすぐには明らかではないが、
和を計算すればket 1が得られるはずだ。
この状態でcircuitを実行すると、得られる出力は
Jをランダムに選んだ場合と
まったく同じになる。
そして固有ベクトルpsi J上で
手順を実行した場合と同じだ。
これも明らかではないが、解析すると真であることがわかる。
そしてついに、これで完成だ。位数発見のための効率的な量子
アルゴリズムが得られた。
レッスンの残りはごく短い部分で、
整数の素因数分解と
位数発見の関係についてだ。
位数発見問題を効率的に解けるなら、
整数の素因数分解も
効率的にできると言った。
これがどう機能するかの主なアイデアを
ごく簡単に説明したい。
完全に古典的な話だ。この部分は実際、
量子コンピューティングとは無関係だ。
ある正の整数Nの
非自明な因数を見つける方法を紹介する。
ちなみに、この方法はNが奇数で、
かつ素数の冪乗でない場合にのみ機能する。
Nが偶数または素数冪乗の
2つのケースは別途処理できる。
その2つのケースの検出と処理には
効率的な古典的手法がある。
この方法は確率的だ。失敗することもあるが、
失敗の確率は最大でも2分の1だ。
独立して複数回実行するだけで
誤りの確率を
指数関数的に速く減らせる。
まず、2からN-1の間でAを
一様ランダムに選ぶ。
次にAとNのGCDを計算する。
GCDがたまたま1より大きければ、
とてつもなく運が良かったということだ。
GCDはNの因数になるので、それを出力して終了できる。
そうでなければアルゴリズムは続き、
AはZNスターの元であることがわかる。
次にAの位数を計算する。ここで量子コンピュータが必要になる。
あるいは別の方法で
位数を計算できるかもしれない。アルゴリズムは
出所を気にしないが、効率的にやる方法は
今のところ
量子コンピュータしか知らない。
Rの位数が偶数なら、AのR/2乗マイナス1と
NのGCDを計算する。
そのGCDが1より大きければ、またNの因数が得られるので出力して終了だ。
そうでなければアルゴリズムは失敗だ。その場合は
最初に戻って別のAを選び
次回はより良い
結果を期待する。
以上だ。ちなみに、
Nの因数がひとつ見つかったら、その因数に対して
再帰的に適用できる。
その因数で割り続ければ、Nの素因数分解が得られる。
なぜこれが機能するのか？
主なポイントが2つある。1つ目は、AのR乗がmod Nで1と合同なので、
NはAのR乗マイナス1を
割り切るということだ。
この2つの文は実際には同値だ。数論の教科書に載っている
mod Nの定義そのものだ。
2つ目は、Rが偶数なら、
ここにあるこの方程式が成り立つ。
これは平方差の
よく知られた公式だ。
実際、この方程式はすべてのRで成り立つが、
ステップ4ではR/2が
整数である必要がある。
この2つの事実を合わせると、Nのすべての素因数は
括弧内の2つの式のいずれかを
割り切らなければならないことがわかる。
なぜなら、それがNが
積を割り切る唯一の方法だからだ。
Nのすべての素因数が
最初の括弧内の式を割り切り、
2つ目は割り切らない可能性もあるが、ランダムなAに対しては
それはあまりありそうにない。だからステップ4でGCDを計算すると、
積が得られる可能性が高い。
Nの素因数のうちいくつかの積だが、
すべてではない。
これを厳密に解析するには
数論が必要だが、かなり基礎的な数論だ。
数論が興味深いと思って
もっと学びたいなら、この解析を自分でやってみるといい。
こういったことを実際にやってみることが、より深く学ぶための優れた方法だ。それはあなたに任せる。
これでレッスンは終わりだ。このレッスンでは、
位相推定問題と、量子コンピュータ上で
効率的に解く方法を扱った。
そしてその解をどう応用して、整数の素因数分解の
多項式コスト量子アルゴリズムを得るかも学んだ。
次のレッスンはGroverの
量子探索アルゴリズムについてなので、ぜひ参加してほしい。
またね。